I think most people are confused about  money most people don't have a healthy  relationship with money there are the  people who think that money is  everything the money is the only  important thing in the world and you  need to chase it down and is your duty  and responsibility and obligations like  it's number one the person walking into  my house or my place of business that's  my next suit that's my next payment  that's my next whatever it's only  focused on money and there's other  people who think money is the root of  all evil and that money is a Bad Thing  money is a tool money helps you get a  lot of things done money helps you go  places money helps you accomplish your  mission money needs to be in your top  five it's just not number one